what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in um
let's get started
um also before I start guys hit that
like button and also sign up for our
Google form for our events we're going
to do events here in London and in the
US so if you want to be notified make
sure you sign up for our Google form
today we're going to be reacting to
Brian debunks feminist on the wage Gap
let's let's end on the wage Gap okay so
Eric can you pull up the pay scale thing
uh scroll all the way down pay scale is
a reputable company that investigated
this
um scroll down a bit more on or sorry on
the chart just stay on stay on this
chart here can you uh Zoom it in just a
tad
um
a little more if you can Eric
yeah that's fine so on the left you have
the uncontrolled gender pay Gap you
commonly hear this one 82 cents for
every one dollar earned by men so
this is when you take all men and all
women and just compare
just like that without taking into
account hours worked profession
seniority
type of job that's that when you control
it
when you control for
like and like so someone working the
same job same qualifications same hours
worked
it's 99 cents
where's that one cent
oh
this just shows that women will always
complain you know men build Society run
the infrastructure basically do all the
hard jobs and if we get a 99
equality
we'll still complain we will still
complain I would say that's within the
margin of error this is like what men
say they're like I gave my woman 99 of
what she wanted but that one percent she
won't get over well I don't know what it
is about our nature we just find things
to criticize men can like be happy like
women like if we're not focused on
something or busy doing something or
raising kids like we just we're just
critics we are big critics the thing is
is that what you have to think about
what these situations is
if there's a discrepancy is there
necessarily does that necessarily mean
that it's due to sexism if there's a
difference between men and women
is it for example the supposed pay gap
which there isn't
is it due to sexism
I would say no I would say it's due to
people's choices
how is it a woman's choice to get paid
less I don't understand what you mean by
that
well they are they aren't paid less
you're talking about hours worked once
but the re like why do we assume it's
gender why why still a difference
when controlling for everything it's
down to one cent but you should control
because why would I as a teacher get
compared to somebody who makes way more
money or even way less money right
exactly so you're talking controlled ads
and people who I hate to say this they
were all coming at me because I said the
feminists are all the teachers are
mostly feminists that didn't have kids
so they raise yours
and the more I see these shows the women
that say they're teachers yes that was
exactly what they are same profession as
me
so even that woman like me as a teacher
comparing to a man that does the same
job as me
in control it's still saying that I make
less money
so that's all
but that it doesn't prove that it's due
to some sort of sexism just because
there's even a difference when it's
controlled what else would it be it
could be all sorts of things like what
well first off even controlled like that
you still have to think about
differences that people make throughout
their life
princess
for example if you choose to get
pregnant
that's going to impact your
pre-populate the world no I'm not
against women getting pregnant what if
you get pregnant on accident what if it
wasn't necessary yeah people get
pregnant not meaning to get pregnant
I thought you said getting pregnant on
acid no
look
if there was a boys club and if it was
if you could get away with paying women
less why would you ever hire a man if
you can pay a woman
30 cents what is it Set uh 70 30 less
you would just hire women
businesses are in the okay a business's
goal is to make money
if you can pay women 30 because they
don't want to get sued for sexism I'm so
tired women want to work in a man's
world work and I I got no problem with
that I got guys guys
oh my gosh I recently have been pissing
off people on Twitter because I said
that men's jobs are more important than
women's jobs it's like duh
um and I can't even do like thought
experiments without people saying that I
hate women but for this one okay I'm for
this
if we are going to go into a man's world
we cannot cry sexism and sexual
harassment
I'm sorry I am tired of women going into
a man's world and then crying harassment
later do the men cry when they get
harassed no do the men cry when their
colleagues bullied them no you went into
a man's world be in a man's world thank
us you would just hire women
but it's clearly and yes I would I'm a
capitalist but if I just hired women I
just think that I would get sued for
something
yes
you probably won't make money yeah yeah
because they'd all take vacation and ask
for raises otherwise corporations would
just be hiring women if you could
actually get away with paying them less
then you pay men
I just disagree you disagree Okay so
okay
do you okay so do you think that what I
pulled up there the pay scale thing 99
Cents yes
I actually think bran is not the best
debater like he lets a lot of things
that these women say slide things that
that are obviously a very good layup
yeah like you just lets it slide or he
doesn't know how to come back well I
don't I think he's more of a moderator
than a debater okay okay yeah I think
that's actually partially why he gets
such good guess is because he just
brings them on to say whatever they want
to say he's not trying to debate with
them or nothing yeah I mean he does a
bit but it's like I mean if you don't
get completely destroyed you might come
back disagree with
their assessment I'm not going to
disagree with their assessment I'm just
what do you think the wage Gap is even
if that right there is a wage Gap I'm
not going to say that um I know what it
is because I don't but still
that's like 99 Cents does anyone else
want to come in on this by the way
podcast I think that's definitely what
we're doing here we're I don't think I'm
gonna fully believe after leaving here
like that that
paper that you showed us so I definitely
need to do more research so I can speak
more clearly about yeah look into it
although you probably made that yeah
probably make what oh I made it I made
the PDF look because uh sexism is very
prominent and I and this is what I'm
tired of they're trying to make us as
women believe that we are oppressed and
believe that sexism is so prominent
because they know we can be easily
propagated they know they know we
believe damn near anything like we
believe in all these conspiracy theories
so that's they take advantage of this if
we if we can get women to believe in
sexism we can control women because then
you can say oh if um you didn't
basically if you don't believe in this
then you don't support women and women
we care about what other people think a
lot and so you basically say yeah if you
don't agree with our opinions and you
break the social contract as women I
mean look at me guys I break the social
contract as women and I get attacked so
mercilessly from women all the time it's
like they want they want to keep us
oppressed quote unquote in our heads so
they can control us thank you look my
opinion on
my opinion is that just because
we're not talking about all like the
bigger the whole picture of sexism
doesn't mean that it doesn't happen and
that piece of paper isn't going to make
me fully believe that it's not real
because it's something that I've fully
experienced Okay so
here's what it comes down to there's
another pay Gap there's not a wage Gap
there there's an earnings Gap so the
question that you need to ask yourself
is not whether it exists but why it
exists and I would say the answer it's
not sexism
so there's a ton of reasons
for the earnings Gap like I already said
the big one is women's choices women
when for example in college they tend to
study different things
so that's one you have to look at for
example hours worked
you have to look at I mean there's a
whole bunch of things
there's different types of jobs that are
worked by men and women there's a ton of
different factors I mean I could pull up
there's another thing we could pull go
lay bricks go get your raise go lay
bright if we want to talk about the wage
Gap like
I don't think we do yeah yeah
okay I'll end it on this
so there's all kinds of gaps right
yeah there's different there's different
kinds of gaps so if we talk about the
wage Gap then we also have to talk about
the more likely to work a dangerous job
Gap
what about or more likely to die on the
job Gap
that's a gap
I said 93 of workplace deaths are men
should we equalize that
you think it should we equalize it so
it's 50 50 workplace but this is what I
mean we only want equality when it
benefits us we don't want equality when
it matters
you just said that women do not take up
the majority of those jobs so
so that's
but
but does it stand to reason that if
you're working a day okay let me ask you
guys a question in order for you to work
a dangerous job you know when they say
women are children like do you hear how
he's talking to these chicks it's like
look it I I understand not all women are
children not all women act like this but
like like do you hear how he has to
break this down in order for women to
understand logic would you have to be
paid more in order to do it
if a job came with the risk of death or
injury would you be like I want to be
paid more for that job
or do you think those jobs should be
better compensated than working in the
comfortable office well they they
already get paid more due to the risks
so I had a couple friends working
construction and there's higher risk in
that so obviously you know they're
getting paid more
to like incentivize right working these
jobs and 95 of construction workers
probably more than 95 are men I would
agree yeah
um but going off like
what you said about choices now you know
obviously men
do work those jobs more and I will agree
that women
choose to not work those jobs more but
at the end of the day like men still
choose to do that job instead of a less
like a lower risk job
yeah
but okay
should we close the gap if we should
that absolutely did not make sense you
almost tried to use the admin that well
men choose to do the higher risk job so
like okay so what was the argument there
yes that's the argument they choose to
do those jobs and the funny thing is Men
A lot of times don't choose to do the
job because they want to get a higher
pay they choose to do the jobs because
they know that they don't do it no one
else would the wage gap which I mean
we've pretty much done shouldn't we try
to close it in other Industries too
don't you think like
that's why that's why
why are more valuable than
regardless of money because all of men's
jobs we need we cannot survive without
the jobs that women do we can survive
without it's actually crazy King the
like how much rage I started by saying
this like it's so crazy to me it's like
this isn't this shouldn't be
controversial the bricklayer is far more
important than me when it comes to value
added to society I may I may make more
money I mean without the bricklayer you
wouldn't have a studio correct thank you
thank you and that's why and that's why
like women we get these high paying jobs
and then we start to think we're like
better than the men but just because we
can monetize Beauty because it's like
where where are women really dominating
it's mostly jobs that monetize Beauty I
know nursing and like teaching is one
thing but honestly those are the
industries everybody complains about I I
saw this I just tweeted this um the U.S
gender employment ratio so it shows like
like the amount of women working so in
1950 it was like 20 and then in uh 2020
oh my gosh this is still only 45 of
women work or that many women unemployed
what
wow that's been only funds yeah but then
I do the total Pages um in the code of
federal regulations
so it's like in 1950 there was less
there was um less than 20 pages in the
regulations codes and now there's close
to 180 pages so it's like the more women
work the more regulations because we're
like oh we need to do everything by the
books oh we need all these rules
it's like it's how Corporate America
like sucks to be honest because it's all
these women that come in and like tell
men how to do things I also realized
another way women and men also like
stems kind of reinforce like the female
point of view basically is by policing
language because they'll say things like
I don't like your tone you don't have to
say it like that and I'm pretty sure I
probably said this like two years ago
like early on in the content to be
honest but it's like um when they do
that and say you should say things a
different way they're saying you should
say things the female way and so women
and men unknowingly are like reinforcing
like the female contract because if you
go and the reason I would say this is
because if you go to male spaces there's
no male con social contract but if you
go into female spaces there's a female
social contract because I can't go up to
my friend and call her a [__] [__]
even if it's true but a man can go up to
a woman and call her a [__] [__] even
when our man can go up to another man
and call him a [__] [__] if it's true
right like men can do it more to each
other than women can and so what that
shows us is that the female way is being
enforced on everybody especially in
Corporate America that's where you get
things like sexual harassment which I'm
not saying there aren't real versions
but I would guess just my gut feeling
that 80 is just like [__] because
it's like if you call a man like an
incel at work he's not going to go
report it or like a loser whatever but
if you call a woman a [__] that's
harassment even if she's being one or if
you call a woman a [__] you say you're
dressed like a [__] you can't say that
in Corporate America even if it's true
aren't those hard gaps to compare
how many people die on the job and then
like
how well like I mean what are you how
would you close the gap of death
we should have maybe more female
construction workers okay more female
roofers so you said choice and so it's
everybody's choice for what they want to
do right and so and that
another problem now she's saying well
they're true
they're willing to do the dangerous jobs
and all this stuff
but it's like the least we can do is be
grateful instead of say well it's your
own fault you're dying that's basically
what she's saying he's been saying it's
your own fault you're dying instead of
saying you're choosing it so if you
don't choose it then where would you
live yeah
that's right
and women choose to go into careers that
happen to be generally speaking lower
paying careers
but the crazy thing is I really think
they have subsidized women's like roles
to where we like we're going to out earn
men and I don't think we deserve it
based on like value in society like it's
just gonna be I mean even Twitter was an
example God that's such real to all
these women getting fired from their
tech jobs you see them on Tick Tock too
just like crying on social media
and it also comes down I'm saying like
people in the same job yeah like we
can't compare two different jobs I think
she's talking about like people in the
same exact job
because like of course you compare like
a construction worker who's earning a
lot of hour to like a woman yeah that's
Choice like she chose to take that lower
paying job and he chose to take a higher
paying job but like maybe like in the
same business or same Corporation or
same job whatever the case
okay I don't even know what she just
said maybe we could
she's basically saying that the CEO
should be paid the same as the secretary
that's what I realized when women get in
control of stuff like we go more towards
equality like egalitarian where men go
into hierarchies like women want to be
more equal where men want a hierarchy
that's the crazy thing like in um they
had like women and men go on an island
and the men were like running [__] in
like a day I have a theory I actually
don't think competence can thrive in an
equal Society no it can't yeah because
you have to be paid for it yeah but I
actually think that we like men
sometimes go into the workforce and just
see like women maybe maybe this this is
just a theory I have but I was thinking
like maybe men like a lot of the
unemployed men that we see they go into
the workforce and they see women getting
like their jobs that they really should
deserve and that's like they're just
like [__] this I'm going out like
they'll do that in Corporate America
they'll employ like they'll promote a
woman and even in colleges like I
remember remember this guy in my high
school was totally complaining because
this chick got into Notre Dame and he
didn't and at the time I was like why is
he complaining she probably just had a
better essay but in high like
hindsight's 2020 I'm like oh he was
probably right and it's kind of like if
if where you're going isn't giving you
like jobs it's just like you're kind of
like [__] it it's just like a working
Theory I have though so don't quote me
on that guys guys make sure you like the
video um subscribe to the channel
um also ring that notification Bell
let's get this video to a thousand likes
so like the video subscribe to the
channel we'll talk to you next time